what if
a lot of times i'll be in a 200 mile run
or something like that
and i'm all jacked up body's broken
mind's broken spirit's broken i started
to say what if i can pull this off
when i first walked into the navy seal
recruiter's office he looked at me and
said there's only been 35
african-americans in 70 years make it
through you know i said to myself
what if i can be the 36th it's the what
if
i can pull off a miracle what if
i can become someone that no one thinks
i can be and just that just me
talking about that i have the hair going
up on my arms
because it makes me just like what if
i can be that guy that people who call
[ __ ] and this and that
and now i'm speaking at tom ferry's
event there's a direct correlation
between
celebrating your wins and wanting to do
more of them see when i was broke
and i was broke longer than i've been
rich you know what i'd always do when i
walk into a store i'd never get what i
wanted
i'd always check the price tag what's it
cost what's it cost
what's the cost what's it cost and when
you're always looking at what it costs
you never get what you want and a lot of
us do that in our lives every day we're
repeating to ourselves what's this
costing me
the sacrifice i'm going i don't know if
i could go through any more
and you lose what you want you got to
quit negotiating the price
right now make the decision that any
price is worth it as long as it's legal
ethical and moral for you to make your
family proud of you for you to make your
dream happen
stop negotiating the price this
negotiation you keep doing in your mind
is this really where i'm supposed to be
this is what i'm supposed to be doing
steals all your energy it steals your
focus
but those of you that get laser focused
become totally immersed in your dream
that know those babies of yours your
parents guess what
they're worth the sacrifice i want you
to know something that the bigger your
dream is
i want you to understand the harder the
grind there listen to me
luck is for leprechauns and you ain't
green
no no no no no i'm sorry it's right here
under the trap take the jacket off i'm
gonna show you i have that one on today
luck is for leprechauns and you're not
green
i'm gonna say it again luck is for
leprechauns and you're not green
i'm not bringing you i'm not bringing
you a fairy tale what i am telling you
is that if you're willing to go beast
mode you can have whatever you want i'm
a living example
you can start from nothing start from
nothing you know the story
mine was a teenage mom start with
nothing grandma had 14 kids
start with nothing two bedroom house one
bathroom mom got kicked out because she
hadn't start with nothing
start with nothing high school dropout
start with nothing
homeless 12 years to get a four-year
degree from the university
start with nothing if you are willing to
grind
now i need to do me a huge favor you
gotta understand this there are two ways
to be successful
right and i don't subscribe to the first
one that's just natural talent
all right i just don't believe people
who are naturally talented are better
than me
i i believe effort and you've heard me
say it your mama might your mama might
come from privilege
your daddy might come from privilege
your daddy might own a company
you might come from proof you might have
a father that can give you everything
your little heart desires but you will
not
outwork me why because i realize that
the bigger the dream
and i need you to see who i have up
there notice when i said beast mode now
i'm not talking about the lion
when i talk about beast mode now i'm
talking about the air
that's very small but that can probably
lift a hundred times his weight
i'm saying that some of you in this room
you might not be a lion yet
some of you in this room you might be a
ad you might have
small beginnings you might not have a
lot of money you might not have a lot of
resources but there's no excuse you're
saying e.t
i'm not that lying you might be the hand
and the aunt
has very little but he's determined he's
strong
he has a dream and a goal and he'll do
whatever it takes
and i need you to understand that the
bigger your dream is the earlier you're
gonna have to get up
the longer you're gonna have to stay up
the bigger your dream is the more effort
you're gonna have to put in and for
those of you
who raise your hand and put up 70 you'll
never see it
you'll never see it for those of you who
are 70
70 percent beast mode 30 gazelle
that's just enough for that other person
i'll do you that's just that's just
enough
for listen to me that's just enough
for the other person who wants just what
you want okay so let me say it like this
because
i want to make sure you get it all right
listen to me i told you i told you
i told you i want you to think about
those goals i want you to taste them
i want you to i want you to be i want
you to internalize it i'm not asking you
to tell me what your goals are because
i'm interested in hearing everybody i
couldn't i couldn't possibly do anything
with it listen this is what i'm telling
you i'm telling you to dream your dream
because i want you to feel it
i want you to taste it i want you to
know how close
i want you just like when the weather is
changing you can feel it i want you to
be able to feel
when you're getting closer to it and
closer to it but more importantly
i want you to know when you dream your
dream that there are other people who
are dreaming the exact same dream
when you said to yourself when the ball
comes out this is what i want to
accomplish
you're not the only person that wants to
accomplish it and now i ask you this
question
what do you do when a thousand other
people
want exactly what you want what do you
do
when you're not the only one that wants
to make a million dollars in your
company you're not the only one that
wants to be the president you're not the
only one that wants to be a ceo
what if you're not the only one that
wants what you want
what if there are thousands of other
people who want what you want you have
to
outwork them you got to out grind them
you got to get
up earlier you got to stay up later
you've got to execute and you've got to
go from 70.
to 120. don't think that because it
hasn't happened
it won't happen sometimes it don't
happen because you ain't ready
sometimes it don't happen because the
world ain't ready
sometimes it don't happen because you're
praying for the wrong thing
you're praying for less than you want
but you're asking what you think is
available
you can't trick the universe like that
sometimes
it hasn't happened be because the the
situation and the time ain't right
so if you're praying for something
working for something
waiting for something that hasn't
happened don't think that it won't
happen
just recharge and renew your vision
some of us don't get what we want
because we haven't renewed and recharged
our vision
most people sign up for the goal and
this is my new awareness they sign up
for the goal and you focus on the goal
and you get really really committed to
the goal and then you got to go through
something to get to the goal and then
you set the goal down
i'm gonna invite you don't sign up for
the goal sign up for the inconvenience
it's gonna cost you
sign up for that sign up i sign up
every day every day to the inconvenience
the goal looks sexy the inconvenience
looks costly
but if you sign up for the inconvenience
then the goal will take care of itself
every day say yes to whatever it takes
no matter what commitment is the key
the moment that you commit yourself then
all
unforeseen incidents people
things that can happen that are positive
begin to come your way and
and the in the basically the whole
thought was the fact
that nothing comes to you until you
commit yourself
nothing comes to you if you're just
going to try but you're not committed
nothing comes to you if you're
just thinking about it it's not until
you take the action step it's not
until you take the direction do the
things start to flow through you
that quote i laminated and i carried it
in my pocket
for almost a year and during the day
i would just have times where i would
feel a little bit like
do i really want to keep doing this and
i would pull that quote out
and i would read it and i'd put it back
in my pocket and it just
gave me fuel for the day
and that fuel lasted until i got through
that very difficult year of leadership
of which it was a turning point year
it was in that year that i um began to
understand i think the deeper
areas of the different deeper
possibilities and thoughts about
leadership itself
it was in that year that i settled the
issue of commitment and
i settled the issue of direction and i
came
out of that year and to be honest with
you ever since
i built on that commitment year of my
life
the only reason i share that with you is
because i have a tendency to think that
perhaps in your life you may be tempted
to sometimes just kind of
throw your hands up and quit
i'm not saying you should always keep
doing what you're doing i'm not saying
that all
but i'm saying don't cheat yourself out
of the possibility
of the potential that's on the other
side of commitment
stay with it long enough to find out if
there's any
fruit in it i promise you this
you'll be glad you did and i have found
and i think you will find also
commitment really is the key let's start
with a metaphor
i want you to think about your life like
a book
a book is divided into chapters some
chapters are boring and a grind to get
through and
others are exciting and you hope they
never end and right now
you're in a chapter maybe this chapter
of your life is a grind
it's overwhelming and unsatisfying and
you feel stuck
reading it over and over again
maybe you want to start a new chapter
but you don't know what the next chapter
is about and so you keep re-reading the
one you're currently in
here's the greatest thing about life you
don't have to know where this next
chapter is going
you just have to start writing it i want
you to envision
a blank page what do you want to write
what do you see for yourself i don't
want you to try to figure out what job
or business you
should write on that page what belongs
on that page are the dreams that you
have for yourself
and your life and all that's required to
start writing
is to start saying yes instead of
telling yourself no
yes you should start that podcast
yes you should go back to school yes
you should try to launch that business
whatever it is that you've been doing
whether you're three years out of
college and it's a job you can't stand
from a major you hate
or it's a 20-year career that you're
just burnt out on
or maybe you stepped away from the
workforce to raise your kids or perhaps
like so many people right now you've
been laid off
this is the moment to write your next
chapter
you're not too late you're right
on time all you need
is a blank page and a pen as steve
maraboli said
we all make mistakes have struggles and
even regret things in our past
but you are not your mistakes you are
not your struggles and you
are here now with the power to shape
your day
and your future and you've got to be
careful
about what future it is that you decide
to shape you have to be careful
about the thoughts that you let inside
your mind so
many people live their life by the law
of
accident never grabbing hold of
something with intention and deciding
that that's what they're going to think
about deciding that these are the
thoughts that they're going to allow in
their mind and
intentionally rejecting other thoughts
but as marcus aurelius says your mind
will take the shape
of what you frequently hold in thought
for the human spirit is
colored by such impressions
and that's why it's so critical that you
decide
the things that you're going to pursue
mentally that you decide what you're
going to hold on to
and you have to make those decisions
based on what you decide
you want to become but it all starts
with that it all starts with knowing
what it is exactly that you want to
become
and recognizing the truth of the way
that the human mind
works whatever you repeat whatever
you repeat you are going to become if
you repeat something empowering you will
become
empowered if you repeat something
self-destructive you will destroy
yourself
but people don't act like that's true
people act like they
are something that the world is going to
tell them who they
are and that once they have a vision of
themselves that they are simply
recognizing the truth
but that's the lie that is the great
fallacy that may be the greatest lie
that we've ever believed that we are
somehow stuck in time
that we are somehow made created and
like a pot of clay
the only thing left is to break and
start over but that's not how it works
the way that the human mind works we are
completely malleable and we are shaped
and tired by what we hold in our minds
so take control of that process decide
who you want to become and no matter
how fake it feels at first
you've got to go down the process of
repetition and shaping yourself the way
that a sculpture
creates that ultimate work of mastery
piece by piece bit by bit day
after day with intention
so that you can finally reveal what you
want to be
if you want motivation to start your day
the right way check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
it continue to believe and i'll see you
there
the simple part that most people don't
understand
is that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future it's as though
our thoughts